you mentioned a number of human rights
abuses that are occurring in Burma and
my question is under the current
government or the government that's to
be elected in the upcoming election
short of a regime change that would
overcome the military dictatorship are
there other mechanisms in the meantime
by which the government can be held
accountable for those human rights
abuses in your opinion so while the
struggle for democracy is continuing are
there other ways to curb the human
rights abuses hold the government
accountable and maybe did to her the
government from engaging in those very
severe abuses I wanted to say no but I
don't want to make you hopeless why I
wanted to say noise because I mean this
is the situation that has been going on
for six decades and we've been talking
about is all over so you you might
expect that people hear it and they are
interested and they wanted to make a
difference and they wanted to bring this
regime to the table to hold them
accountable and therefore we've been
lobbying so hard we've been advocating
for the commission of inquiry into war
crimes and crimes against humanity and
as of now we have only 13 countries I
mean not that I'm hopeless but I think
it'll take us a while to get to a
certain point so I think as of now what
we can do is just keep pushing the
government I mean the international
community as well as the u.s. so with
that I wanted to remind all of you I
have some information
the back I hope you can take a look at
them and pick them up and also I I'd
like to urge you to please sign up on
our sign up so that i can add you on our
listserv and then send you the
information because coming in November
after the election with us campaign for
Burma we're going to conflict start
pushing in for a house resolution in
order to get the US government support
because here back in August erlend of
sep tember president obama and the US
government is already making making it
public that they're supporting the
commission of inquiry but there's no
action taken yet so we have to making
these agreeing and having these promise
but also we have to put this into action
so that this promise can be effective so
i'm telling you we're going to need your
help and I really urge you to please
sign up does anyone else want to as for
me that after the elections the
government government may want to to
have the impression in the international
community that we are elected government
we are responsible government we are
constitutional government then they will
try to you know restraint lit at least
they will try as much as they came to
restrain their humor it's a juice I
think to be optimistic and another thing
is that if they think there is no direct
challenge to the authority throughout
the military because there will be some
elected members in the government one or
two maybe but that may also have a you
know impact the degree of human rights
are Jews not much I think that's my
expedition
yes it may not be possible it probably
is not possible for you Myra to answer
this question in this setting but when
you said that you spent 10 years as an
internally displaced person it blew my
mind and I'm wondering how two people
live for so long essentially running
around in the jungle how how do they
survive if you can describe that briefly
you could probably write a very long
book about it but if you could just
summarize how do people survive and also
I presume it's still going on now and
what is going on now and in that context
many of you who was born in America and
has never fled for lives you have the
idea like what is going on why you have
to you have your country and why you
have to be internally displaced in your
own country well interesting huh but I'm
telling you this is burma this is not
the united states so yes 10 years but
thank God I was born and then i'm up to
i was 10 years old it's still different
from if i were there at this age because
the suffering the feeling will be
different but because i was a child so i
didn't really get to see that suffering
so much so but but
how how did that happen of course with
we had to flee for lives as I as I
described earlier but how did we survive
it's very interesting thing and I'm
always impressed by the people who are
left behind these days guess what they
don't have homes they have to sleep one
night here one night there but they
don't give up you tell them okay your
life is hard I talked to some of my my
distant relatives I was like life is so
hard in the internally displaced area
why don't you leave and come to the
refugee camp they're like no our home we
don't want to go away from it we will
rather die here so how do they survive
well they are pretty wise although they
don't read any ABCD they have their food
let's say they did work on their farm
and then they collect the food a by the
end of the year and then they highly let
a place where they figure the military
regime the military troops has no clue
where these places and they keep it
really safe but also on top of that they
I mean they don't keep it close by where
the village is because when the village
is destroyed and then the land mines are
planted they won't be able to come back
so they keep the food somewhere else and
then also when they they set up their
villages they don't kind of like set it
up for a long term they just built up a
little shed with the bamboos and then
leaves roof and then they leave their so
that even if this home is destroyed this
house is destroyed but it doesn't take
away so much of my energy because if I
have to build it up another time yes I
can build up again so and also it's not
only men nowadays women become the head
village leader because usually when the
troops came into
the village they would look for men and
then send them to the front line to
become our minds reverse order to carry
heavy ammunition in a munitions and all
this stuff so now the women become the
head man of the other villages and then
I guess sometimes it yes the military
regimes are very tough to to the ethnic
people but also at the same time when it
comes to women it's kind of like a
little tricky for them to play the game
with women they just cannot take them
straight out and then do whatever they
wanted to do with them as the way they
did to that would have done two men so
it's a kind of like they have their own
little unique way of not wanting to give
up so they would do whatever it takes
for them to be able to survive in jungle
do answer your question okay hi I'm from
the region but I've no expertise at all
in Burma but I'm just looking at a title
of this talk democracy in Burma and I'm
just wondering whether is there any
symbolic political significance in
calling it Burma and not Myanmar that it
is correct so why not call it democracy
in Myanmar so in using Burma supposed to
Myanmar just wondering is there any
political activism just in choosing the
name by which you call the country well
the very easiest way is that the regime
changed the name of the name country the
country named Erma tumi amar without
anyone's consent so it's almost like I
changed my name without letting anybody
know but I'm telling you I used to
change my name I used to add on my name
make my legalize my name in the years
but I had to go through two months
process opposing a name but here a
country name that holds five
sorry 50 million people but they change
the country name overnight without
nobody knows so that is the very easy
way to understand it yes actually boom
frankly speaking your mom makes more
sense than bummer bummer is actually
Berman's romance and Burma is a bummer
propa the major ethnic group and thirty
percent of the ethnic people have the
Quran Sheehan more refined chain so
altogether I'm Emma it does make more
sense but the problem is the messenger
not message because of the military
government not in the minute it is the
problems The Messenger has rather than
message think think of it I think you
can think of it the way you think of a
corporation that has let's say become a
major polluter or had some huge scandal
and they changed the corporation name
and hope that people will not know that
this is still the same corporation come
on in you money Tom lead our new nanga
sooner you get nope i'ma palma sola
nominate hola no ague the napa leather
yo te quiero parma pseudonym yo yo mas
will nominate yamato Blackie Danone our
own avatar a macaque 00 09 yo Maaloula
yogesh a [ __ ] Shakira namida GA hulu
llamas open area so go tomorrow tech a
good Marlin uma pinchando Terry Succi
teilani Pangaea new nava do chem Apollo
Louise Roe y no one no Mariano like a
Porsche on American Idol inaba novel
atomic oh no sorry we lost my utopia
Paloma chain I Duvall
for the name change Obama was used as
bama under the British colony however
after this regime they change into
Myanmar and and and UN is using it and
also another point is after the
independence from British now for not
apart which is the SBDC government the
current government they change all those
names who significant in the you know
independence error like Adama who is the
the activist monk who raval again
against the colony those names is
changed by the regime into you know our
other names so this in that context they
change into yema as well
George
thank you I wanted to ask a question
given the strength of religious feeling
both among Buddhist and Christian
populations in Burma why do you think
the the religious groups and the
churches have been able to do so little
why did the saffron revolution fail I
wonder if people could say a little more
about that and a related question for
many of us in here in the West we really
don't understand how a raging with such
a small support base and with such
strong support for ants ants whoo qi &
for her party it seems to us from the
outside can survive for so long I wonder
if some of the commentators could
address these questions for us thank you
I think I'll take the second part
hopefully the last part i living for you
ok the second part why we're so many and
we're supporting on sausage and we can't
get anywhere hey I'm asking you
seriously how much power do you have do
you think you might be as strong as
buried at a chinese government no so no
matter what we're doing remember back in
two thousand seven the resolution it was
put on the UN security security council
table and the china and the rush I just
vetoed it and then that's it so we're
we're talking about here the regime
itself is seem to be small and they
probably don't have very strong people
to support them or not too many people
to support them but they have strong
people those who hold on to the power
the power that we don't have so
yeah that is very hard to Nevada in al
Cowen's and apache mar 0 nada para un
ano Mysterio John Jenna Alamo pathways e
pina fue president our own to a
controller controller darkness road to
an attacker ena ena i'ma swing lever to
Anna neta neta nayyar a hello gugu zulu
doodles in 70 AD chickadees reliever
tonari on a blown engine genetically na
baba Volusia quail elestra nobunaga
hazama michio to a mushy de cachoeira do
you miss yo yo yo MC de cachoeira do ro
to an Apollo naughty balaiah no Peleliu
mom can go to your mm come to a tad
million become a corner on that road to
you anna powell tbell eritrea jajaja
Loomis an Aloha determined olu para fyz
really be true nee-san Jen Bielema Lou
la tenue Cheney k APPA na Jeong with
rudy stebih you can match a song get up
on oh why the sufferer evolution fail
even though obama is strong in the as a
Buddhist country because in 2007 all
these monks were protesting very
peacefully and the government cracked
down very harsh on them because the
regime has no religion they don't
believe in any religion and they will
kill anyone who threaten their power
they will even kill their sister brother
or mother and they would do any humane
it is just to hold on the power so that
even though we are strong as Buddhist a
religious leader we cannot compete with
them because they will do whatever to to
hold their power so that's why we fail I
just wanted to ask a question that may
be 0 cosida and Joe Santa and professor
Scott my answer is it connected with the
previous question if when we look at
suffering Revolution and the Buddhist
monks use the Buddhist symbols rituals
like butta nuku the knock comma and then
you also use prayer of loving-kindness
all this Buddhist symbolism are very
powerful but when Jose and I said our
social structure in Burma was like more
hierarchical pyramid rather than
horizontal the horizontally diverse but
when we look at suffering revolution
movement we have a lot of ethnic areas
mo and Christianity is like second
largest religion in Burma and the thing
was that for me as a Christian it's
sometimes it's hard to completely
immerse into this Buddhist symbolism and
I I started learning only
loving-kindness prayer when suffering
revolution started I wasn't quite used
to it but when it comes to this movement
how could we how could the buddhist
monks use more inclusive symbolism
symbolism that can persuade other ethnic
groups into your movement and professor
Scott writes a little bit about this
Christianity as a source of distance
from their Dolan people and I'm just
wondering how we could
inclusive approach from the perspective
thank you cara mia chihuahua power to
y'all whoo-hoo genuity he de Porres raga
repair futaba dhalinyarada me da
bootiful little Perez Osaka are alone
tiwari a low otaku genoa parraba una
pure accounting American teacher a
seasonal una puta Papa who along with
Noah papa now the checker Cooper Denicos
una canzone Zurich Oliver kuzunoha a new
year hurry pues lo yeah borabanda aya
para aya Tina paga said Alicia Rios agua
la makan abu true champion rider through
the map you surah harmony nagarajan
oobata yaba pow enemies way no alone
pawan I'm re not really a TI kouka lady
Shakira Xenu de palma lunar ET of
captured a mo naman a hamachi retina
pong vámonos a la fecha de Kock a
teenager heriot-watt i believe oh hello
you need a hearty an apology boo boo hoo
nah man in acuña gamma PP&E retained re
nette
sujin a resume to a ph of our three how
with Noga te arawa now about yoga on a
babalu jean-luc within 10 centimeter
suta is dot is for forever everyone for
the universe for the Peace of the
universe and we pray for the people it's
all inclusive it's not just for you know
the white people or not for the black
people or you know it's all for the
humanity and also our the boycott petani
konasana which is the bike quote a
religious bike or that we did impose on
the spdc is because of its showing that
we don't accept anything from the from
the regime and we are just you know
doing as a religious white cord to them
and what is happening in bama is not
only happening to the barman's it's also
happen to the ethnic minorities so what
we do as monks in 2007 revolution is not
to get any powers we urge the government
to start in national reconciliation
process with all sin su Qi and all
ethnic minorities so this is what we do
and also in this movement everybody can
participate as far as I understand all
the religions differentiate glutes and
bad evil soul of our loving kindness is
all religions teach love and loving to
have loving kindness towards each other
to any people so it is not very
different but very difficult to follow
by other religions I think the ethnic
people in Burma it is very much
equivalent to the non-violence and
best passive resistance led by Mahatma
Gandhi in India this is something like
that every religion can understand
easily i think the loving kindness that
are citing the meter sutra is the same
and botanicals not consumer that means
that they are not receiving any answer
donations from the military government
that is the same as the excommunication
in the Christian Church Buddhist monks
are trying to communicate the regime
because they are Buddhist majority of
them that's a very similar thing with
other religions oh I don't have much I
don't have much to add I suppose it's
the question of how how is it possible
for regime with so little popular
support to nonetheless persist it's
worth it's worth pointing out that in
1990 they actually won the election and
for a change they counted the votes and
then the Parliament was simply not seen
this was a large democratic movement of
major proportions and when Alison said
she was released I think it's would the
de payin massacre was when one year two
thousand three when she went from town
to town to see her supporters the number
of people grew and grew and grew and
grew and it was quite clear that this
was also a revolution in the making and
then there the regime essentially
blocked her motorcade and killed we
don't know how many people so that was
if you like a growing people's
revolution that was crushed and so was
the saffron revolution and what's
interesting to me is that it leads to a
question to Google cita that if you have
a thousand or two thousand troops are
willing to shoot monks you can put down
the saffron revolution and the question
is which military units were willing to
do that
one imagines that they they couldn't
have been just any soldiers they had to
be specially trained units perhaps he
could respond to that Tom hakuna
circulatory copy me Lou who's in a
digital in a tight okay I tomorrow Oh
through a TTL [ __ ] Malecha me Oh drew a
pumpkin in this row to hoe with a
naturally whom java marked with a true
using scrap you're a friggin TI OMAP
nacho poop you're a comedic on a long
walk through wall at oviedo who don't ok
me too with your Akash aroma tour groups
you shop Chidori tomorrow within 10 a TC
Daria Oh through seed cuckoo to Italy me
a maybe right through of Muhammad even
empty so epr affordable you see you dar
a luz ain't in a row digitaria wooden
Lucy choo of your kind of everything
Cameron light infantry division those
soldiers who shoot the truer the monks
are from the Allied tapety lig light
infantry division 7 7777 yeah um when I
spoke to them at the shwedagon pagoda
during the several revolution when we
negotiate with them they you know they
didn't listen to us and also when I
asked to take off their shoes because
you know when you enter the pagoda you
have to know take off your shoes when I
accent they didn't hear me however when
I you know poke them and to tell them
but at the time being kind of responsive
and I think that those soldiers were
drugged by the regime and they will not
normal and they will do it seems like
they will do whatever you know the
regime all so that is the situation
thank you everyone for coming today I
had two questions one is there's a lot
of talk now in Burma about the growing
civil society and there's more NGOs and
more CBO's and at the at the same time
there's been a pretty big crackdown on
religious institutions in Burma since
the saffron revolution soy nadie se DIC
would speak a little bit about what's
happened to this Sangha since it faded
for Manila national attention and the
second thing I'm curious about for gusty
10-4 miras how your own faith fuels your
activism in doing this because I feel
like that's a uniting factor that people
of different religions in Burma are
resisting the military regime even if
they may be of different faiths so if
you could speak well about that
personally
Angelina Lara's raaga and Eureka
terramax pollution SOT harmoo killer
citlali la laguna torre second ahaha
feet re namaha via video na ba ba Lola's
roti angie la lucia to yokubou paya with
no te arataura and use Randall ooh la la
cubana who booty are we bound in yellow
lugar domina vaca pavan Lulu to see a
new yacht I am so I was around
chittenango ma Oh nagib chicken nangal
raya Presidium which way will you become
an angle a garage luyanda video i took a
dare you chew toy volusion camino para
la Makka Moo to Geneva wanna talk to
Janine dama dama to lubime minimal uber
min hua nan Galu members are novel una
parte uma cerveja cantata a cool ever d
leucanthemum unit to a low need a low
near comin ova da faragonda video Cubano
laser 09 gonorrhea and here we go to Idi
Amin oh yeah Bobby 302 a loop in matara
ha oh and you retire de la pena tu yo
quiera que ela falou que Luciano and
Juliana [ __ ] Oh blue dome Lake aquarium
hi Nadine st. Joe TV drama jane yolen su
novia Molly yes they are mobile or NGOs
in Burma however he has to follow the
regimes instructions and orders and they
cannot operate freely for his herbal in
2006 Nagas or 2008 Nagas cyclone when it
happened international NGOs wants to
donate aids and money to the people of
victims directly however the regime acts
them to donate to them to international
community to them not directly to the
people so you know there are a lot of
restriction like that
and there is no freedom to operate like
that unless you're not a regime open to
tell the community international
community that you can come and operate
freely but in reality it is not the case
so that is the first question andreoni
do premi pony legal teenagers who regard
no te fue campeón de la ley you got
windier car- mikuni ago you couple doc
before you go Whitney let it touch your
home pony dil apna dal Oh No teach a
lollipop Tony's aluminum ademas no train
to look horrible Teegarden evo Savio
colombiano day oh yes you'll ever pooey
a balding I a'chili Johnny Hakuna kubada
coupe llamado Umizoomi on to a piano be
da b'hala slow internets anybody level
Maccabiah aponi did you Jeremy re
madhavi onto a part of the local 80 d
teruhiko Wilma do Lujan we capilano
through suya network job tonight ending
Elena alguna trua Finnegan anivia pedo
Canadian and there are more pressures on
the monks because it is near it is
getting closer to the normal 7th
elections and they send those student
monks who are studying at the monastery
in Rangoon to their hometowns after the
Sabbath month because they don't want
you know the monks to be in the city and
to to see what is going on and they
don't want amongst to go and you know
use internet and you know spread the
news so that is the situation on the
monks
she did put in it's a question about
religions right and that people who
different religions are working together
sorry what's the second question I went
to me personally I have to say that such
situation is almost like beyond my
comprehension but why I'm doing what I'm
doing is because it's almost like you
already step into the situation and you
can step back and I do have a hope that
there will be a brighter future but I
don't know how long that'll take so
basically I'm living and living on the
day i am the moment I mean now taking
the courage and the energy from there
and trying to move on and trying to
achieve whatever that comes or or
whatever that i believe that i am trying
to fight for I mean it seems like Mike
my answer is so vague but I actually
it's almost like this is the best answer
that I can give because it's so hard to
say yes we're going to get to this
destination next year because things
that we've been fighting for all these
years and since my grandparents and then
a well before my grandparents i believe
and also my grandparents and both my
grandparents died already and many of my
uncle's died my arms and I hear my age
and perhaps I really know how many more
so yes positive but then also do a qui
ont de coco kwara hello vino un cielo yo
ho de ho jai ho na ho ug dejar de abu
dawood on a cow say no to our a dejar do
gällivare oso diabolo christian ever
drew huge ulema Islam am gili meno jul
aug nine Tahu g Maserati ano gawa to go
mizzou java zou lu t is a Caliphate
Ariana Maduro korea llama party near a
coil aku tau siapa who a llama lever a
tortilla many vows I love Aug muzu
Oliver quaid-e-azam la familia y mi
moneda yokoyama are equal pues no border
alabama yahoo who the new Oliver togg
abramo okay Donna me Shiva puja nae
maeum oh no no kujaku Lulu me da ba ba
ba da misuzu gonna lose re at work count
you to a party do you know pooja slept
at a parolee who's in your personal life
ah no pudo let approach are a hobby
as boda say what you believe is what you
what you are worship and and Buddha have
no problem of you know other religion
religions and differences and people
will be different people have different
beliefs Christians will have their own
belief Jews and also other Muslims and
so on if you look at your fingers they
are not the same they are different so
it's okay to be different and for my
personally I believe in religion that
are more beneficial to the to the people
that is my own belief John Arnold luda
nima allameh near and SE tarda me to go
alone in my belly inflation
knowledgeable money it worth it luda a
la st. hugging to ninja mamu mamu porno
Aloha drove Aquarion yamaha el utara
dibawah dr to that I need i'ma Ottawa
coolio killing a yahoo know it is
natural that you know all the human has
their own beliefs and this is what it is
hi I I just want to give 2 comments
actually I'm Korean and as many of you
might know might not know Korea was
actually not really democratic on 287
and things might get better and
hopefully it will happen also in Burma
because in 87 the government which was
actually mostly military personnel at
the time wanted to extend the presidency
by changing the Constitution on their
own way and in 87 and 86 there was a
huge demonstration and all over the soul
basically and people basically made it
possible and they change it and the
Constitution basically limited
presidency 25 years single time and
that's the time basically I'll Korea
chain that i'm not talking about North
Korea South Korea changed basically to a
more democratic country as you might be
able to see at this point so I think
that's some hopefully you will be
realized in the future and another thing
I I was just interested in about the
comment professor Scott or a question
professor Scott asked about the Burmese
soldier that what were they thinking
actually at that time and in 1980s in a
city called Kwangju which is south
western part of Korea actually there was
a huge uprising for democracy and
basically they the government they
crashed the whole thing and my realm of
my relatives actually passed away at the
time I'm not from that my mom is from
that area so and that information was
blocked and people didn't know actually
because the city was totally blocked
there was one journalist from Germany
who happened to be there and he was able
to have all the data yeah he was able to
get get out of the country with the data
to Japan and there was how that actually
event was broadcasted
so anyway so there was this question 15
20 years later so what were they
thinking actually the soldiers because
we are the same Korean and most of the
soldiers were not really military men a
lot of them were conscripted they had to
be in the military for two years and
they were just sent to the city and
basically it's still an ongoing
discussion and I think it's still in
Korea it's kind of taboo people don't
want to talk about this especially those
who wore participated in it and I don't
think the government makes available who
participate it actually in that
particular event and at list from some
snippets of it it seems like they were
just thinking okay these are my enemy
like they were there all as all of you
know they're not thinking like
rationally ok these are also fellow
Koreans who want democracy they just
follow the order and it's not i'm not i
wouldn't say necessarily it's there for
it but anyway the situation
circumstances made it like that it seems
like and perhaps that can give us some
idea why how burmese soldiers actually
at that time when they attacked or like
when they were confronted with
protesters how what they were thinking
basically maybe it was very difficult
for them to even conceived at the time
if there are people coming to them so
and you know it's worth the question I
suppose is democracy will eventually
come to Burma in a real form but the
question is what will be left that is to
say not only have the life chances of
two generations been devastated but in
addition to that the country is being
plundered for its natural resources the
teak the minerals the panning for gold
along the irrawaddy there's a kind of
destruction of the environment as the
neighboring countries rush to take all
the valuable commodities out of the
country and of course they're millions
of Burmese who've left the country as
well they're probably more than 3
million Burmese legally and illegally in
Thailand more than half a million in
Malaysia now the numbers in India are
substantial a large number in China so
in fact Burma has for the last half
century been hemorrhaging much of its
talent and educated people and the
people who would be the promise of a
better Burma some of those people will
go back if democracy returns but the one
has to ask what will be left to the
environment and what will be left of the
human resources and so on after this
long period of devastation I didn't mean
to have a soliloquy place
well the cook at the point you just
raised of course makes things much more
complicated because my question or my
comment is especially to the two
activists so in the beginning I heard a
little bit use specifically saying that
there might be some hope in opening the
country a little bit now my question to
the two activists is do you think that
by having more treat although it's
exploitation as well but more more three
that you might have a more economic road
may be a little bit of middle-class
maybe people who don't feel so afraid
anymore of the military and in that
sense create a situation where people
will be more willing to on the one hand
demand their rights and on the other
hand have people who are soldiers who
just don't obey orders as brutally as
they do in the past and maybe a final
question to you if I may does the
government try to dissuade people from
joining the Shanga by by not becoming
monks for it so that's reducing their
power by having people not entered their
group thank you
Lucilla Oh Marty Malusi wife ami tomar o
2 15's where you met Phillip jong-il on
lo mejor agarro Buddha known a girl Nina
séjour nasa channel okie women eager to
Jonny Gomes way no car ematic of a loser
or 1000 per milliliter aku lagi na far
linear a Aloha see why Amanda maya na
fire manasa we nee na found a nice Adele
you reachable 00 soda wazoo yamaha bao
toward a guide porto de Navarre para
karma Hoda madurai Hoda when Andy
paducah change em a sacar de Medici duty
CNT ma area are a convoy dejo de la
corte madera hardy na payenge wicked a
row na by n which I jaja na ba da li jiu
shi dou mei Peduto go juicy mom hope
cool a ver una goma yanira que decir a
nacho tomar una relación de decir Tanya
kid ory at hua nan yon doma sidet
yamalieu muy bonita palma Metal Men
inaba to Yakuza kaduche are a sitter
dragoon nuclei arevalo puta puta barata
chay-ara jongseo hamari tupido poppin
lemon ave a bombardier chanda aam a hulu
peter Yarrow synod rubios in Elam
evasive our eligibility by getting more
trains and getting more equal you know
investments in bama and to try to change
it slowly I think it is just a dream
because you know for my personal
experience I have lived there for 20 80
20 years and I what I
scene is the people of Burma are not
benefiting anything from that from from
the government all these resources are
used for their to build the military
only not for the people and if you go
there at the tourists you know you will
spend money and although many will go to
the regime because the tax and
everything has to pay to the government
so the people were getting more and more
you know poor and the military regime
and their cronies will be you know
getting stronger and stronger
Polly without a low hondahonda aroma
shiva hulu have a pony will be loved
easily hungary saluting a huma daya
timid hua hua zhu yawen an assignment
wire our new internet madonia Ramu
hawlucha Damien do I araujo no kuruma
shiny was a good Tommy gr a new era meu
PP PP moody veggie bar L pony you my big
winner may be happily nima maybe when I
miss Eva Padilla Palmeiro Queen diga Oh
blue yamla toggle ooh reloaded and
locate a pony surah hulu Nevada Utah
basura osamu mubarak at hua Jiao Obama
may be by with no pasa nada yeah maybe
maybe she Wow there is no note like you
no restriction to become monks from the
regime however they put restriction on
the you know junior monks way you know
they gonna go freely and they could they
kind of go or two in the neck a phase
and you know you cannot go there you
cannot go there so this kind of
restrictions are on the younger months
and for the monks in Burma we are not
allowed to cast any votes as a political
reasons no not for religious reasons
because we are not allowed to support
you know any particular members or any
parties for our own benefits so that is
why we're not allowed to vote we have we
have time for one or two brief questions
hi I have a question that I'd like to
please direct to Lou Gossett at I'm
curious if you could please comment on
how how historically minded the
participants in this effing revolution
are and by that I mean to what extent
today sort of consciously conceive of
their activism as a continuation of the
clerical resistance to the British
colonial regime to what extent do they
take inspiration inspiration from that
legacy and if not how do you explain
their disconnection from it do you see
that as a symptom of the breakdown of
the education system could comment on
the historical 2 and so on and see their
historical the continuation of that
divine a tomato mcgovern who tomorrow
yes a new letter to underway with a new
top or a bottom I'm a bow Pluto langara
to Rehoboam oh no Tommy Eugene Oregon
power get a pod raga pujiono objetivo
dor-win opieop when are u janu tiragon
opieop when Allah d yunh alia to
Bevacqua Nara now the Shia do DP an
objection malouda a low juju me luna
nuova DOMA tia dar che KU yaala are you
open ie Oh Laurie Johanna caliber tipo
de la ooh la misma luna alum kong's
avocado ama got a poodle
mahalo trullo toggle avait des bois de
la ni lo lo with lo lleva kuwa through
lunch in hullabaloo you are a battalion
landing with a note eatin area no Dava
yeah it is true that in history context
those activists monk and people like csn
and Ultima revolve you know again under
the colonial rule as we are as bodies we
are following the Bois de way Mon up
path because Buddha enlightened after he
did good things to the humidity and he
so as followers we have to follow his
path by doing good to the people and you
can say that you know we are following
you know Buddha path or you know get
inspired by the people like see I said
Adama who did revolve under the colonial
rule one more question right um my
question is um what is the ethnic makeup
of the Democratic Party in Burma and
also I'm going back to what professor
Scott was saying you know ventually the
democracy will come but um for I feel
like for a lot of ethnic people you know
especially like I mean I can speak for
the kitchen group you know there I feel
like the main concern is to be its own
state you know so after the democracy
eventually come what's in it for that
you know will they become their own
country or with what Burma become like a
I guess a better democratic country
where you know all the ethnic groups can
live together peacefully
I think we would rather say federalism
system because right now I mean we don't
talk about having your own country we're
just talking about your autonomy but
even that it's not possible I mean your
people from Kachin State had to flee for
lives women were raped and the homes
were taken away the lens are confiscated
and it happened for the whole country so
if everyone wants their own state so
it'll be at least at their own country
then burrow will become eight countries
at least so that is not really possible
so our I think our best bet is federal
federalism system where it's almost
taking for quite a simple example like
the US where we have 50 states but also
different state leaders governmental
structure come together to DC to form
the main government I guess that is our
best bet and in the coming elections
there will be about 40 political parties
contesting and I'll drop those for the
political bodies only six bodies are for
the whole all the constituency's and
other 30 almost yes about 30 parties are
ethnic parties they are contesting on
their own region only on the N region
this
the Italian Aria quite well my suit
you know little of God or tiny light
Emma are you quite rapoo Tory Italian
rmr with an award or take me to Bordeaux
coming out there Oh Pocoyo lai chi gong
qi ma po Aloha Tony are retained on your
the Pima along the onion of petrified on
super TV dog dupioni days hello I've
ever didn't do now Apollo be rude ally
with a new khaki need apple a que
recuerdo garments with a harrowing to
deepening such a male she did jaja
quattro booze or attained ideal male
cones on panio mcwhertor Maduro you know
woodham aroma charm you dammit i nee naw
nee nee tomorrow so your delirium or a
Lucy Council email that was near
actually the ethnic nationalism is on
the and growing in Burma compared to
immediately after the independence I
think during that days of the Kings
Burmese Kings the center and periphery
relations the relation between the
federal central government and the
periphery areas are more harmonious than
nowadays because there are only two
connections do links between the central
government and the ethnic areas during
the days of the Kings the first thing is
the military service when Burmese Kings
want to attack Thailand they order all
the ethnic areas him how many soldiers
from the area that is the thing nothing
is taxation and once a year you have to
say some amount of money or some amount
of forest produce read our produce to
the central government that's all other
than those two things they have that
total autonomy in the area after that
military government came to power in
1962 there are more suppression that's
why as no nationalism in barbarous now
getting higher higher if they can solve
the issues know that the genuine
Federation it will be over I think I'm
afraid we have to bring this to a close
I want to thank
myra and you chose on top for coming and
for all of you for coming and finally I
want to thank Oliver pllc for having
organized this event thank you